the biggest football event in nevada
state history is coming up on monday
sports director chris matthews joining
us live in city with more on the big
monday night football game between the
rape of course the raiders christian
everybody's excited about this thing
it'll be a record study night in vegas
more than 65 thousand fans packing the
legion stadium for the season opener now
the last time the raiders hosted the
ravens at home was in 2017 and baltimore
won that game 30-17 that game was played
in oakland this one will be in las vegas
in a domed stadium where it could get
very loud the ravens know it's going to
be crazy inside the death star it'll be
any other game you know just a great
great team you know great all-around
team he's going to have a monday night
fight how about that that's what it's
going to be people call and say what
hotel you stand i said the one they drop
us off at
and then we play the team that we're
prepared to play so that's the extent of
anywhere we play whether it be las vegas
or anywhere else
i'm pretty sure the plane's going to
drop us off in las vegas
all right no mistaking las vegas ravens
had another running back go down today
they're bringing in their third
stringers now le'veon bell's probably
going to play he'll play on monday
coming up at five what are the raiders
saying about that home field advantage
will it be tough to pull off the upset
kirsten it's gonna be a great time out
there yes it is thank you chris and
check this out first allegiant now the
luxor getting in on the silver and black
spirit if you take a ride down i-15 it's
hard to miss the statue at the hotel now
sporting a raiders eye patch setting the
tone for monday night football hey we'd
love to see your spirit on display send
us some photos of you all decked out in
raider gear